minneapolis thank you thank you thank
you for another fantastic weekend you
guys are awesome
june shows coming up hollywood june 4th
i'm at the troubadour it's going to be a
really cool show june 24th i'm in des
moines iowa one night only june 25th
headed to omaha nebraska one night only
and back at brea california
june 30th one night only as well get
your tickets to those shows and all
shows at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com
ryan sickler on all your social media i
want to say again thank you for your
support i appreciate everything you guys
are doing whether you're new here or
whether you're an og thank you for the
love please if you're watching on
youtube subscribe wherever you watch or
listen subscribe
it makes a difference it really helps
the show all right turn those
notifications on
and enjoy the honeydew every tuesday
y'all all right if you need more do i
get it
check out the patreon the honeydew with
you all we just hit 100 episodes okay
and i can again thank you enough for
that support for real like
if you don't know what the show is it's
called the honeydew with you all and i
highlight the low lights with you all
we've done 100 episodes now
and we've heard some of the wildest
stuff all right
it's five bucks a month if you sign up
for a year you get over a month free
and
you get the honey do a day early ad free
at no additional cost all right so if
you or someone you know has that story
that has to be heard please submit it to
honeydewpodcast gmail.com hopefully we
get to do an episode together all right
i want to thank you guys for your
support on the tour as well night pass
nation tour continues to roll on and add
dates
in june alone here all right we're going
to be at the troubadour for a really
cool show june 4th des moines iowa one
night only june 24th omaha nebraska one
night only june 25th and brea improv in
brea california one night only june 30th
now
you guys know what we do over here we
highlight the low lights and always say
these are the stories behind the
storytellers but today we have a very
special episode all right we just hit
that hundred episodes on patreon so what
i decided to do today was take a day off
a bit you know what i mean we're
highlighting the low lights every week
for y'all so i brought in one of my
favorite guests to sit down and
highlight y'all's low lights all right
we're gonna go through 10 of my favorite
episodes these aren't just the only 10
by the way there are 90 more of these
and it was a tough decision but these
are 10 of some of my favorite episodes
and i'm gonna highlight those lowlights
with the one and only joshua what's
going on how you doing man i'm doing
great um i'm very excited to have you
here this is going to be a different
episode before i explain all of that
please plug promote everything and
anything josh wolfe uh
well the podcast that i started doing
with my son jacob called hey man is out
and it i have to tell you man it's
it's the it's my the thing that i'm i've
never had more fun doing anything in my
life this dude like i really just enjoy
him
he's somebody who knows how to push my
buttons so he gets me in ways that other
people don't he tells really
embarrassing stories about me that
nobody else knows
it's like
and we just have great banter and so
i've just loved and you know the most
important thing dude
when you get kids his age you you think
you're done spending time with him
do you know what i mean so this is
really cool bonus time i get to have
with him i mean i didn't realize like
when i could stop spending time with my
parents till my mom left and my dad died
yeah yeah
i was like i think they i think maybe
they think i'm on my own
they want to stop hanging out with me
and uh and then um just my tour dates
man my shows have been selling out like
crazy yeah dude and my [ __ ] thanks man
and the show the the energy of the shows
have been insane comedianjoshwolf.com
for tour dates but in may i'm out in
grand rapids and then i am in oh comedy
on state in madison i've never been
there before either i heard it's fun i
hear it's fantastic amazing i hear it's
one of the best clubs in the country and
then i'm all guys i am a bit of a road
[ __ ] so if you're listening and you
want to know comedianjoshwolf.com
and josh wolf comedy on all social [ __ ]
well congrats on all of that i want to
say this like
and maybe
this resonates with you but i would say
like
now knowing the life that i finally have
starting in my late 40s but being happy
and content
and grateful
and humble
and seeing what i'm able to give my
daughter you know my stepson's working
with me you know like that to me
when i think back to all the [ __ ]
and all the pain if i would have known
then like hey if you go through this
this is gonna happen i'd have been glad
to walk through that i just did it every
day because i knew i [ __ ] had to but
man
i feel like that payoff is and maybe you
feel the same way but how great is that
well you know it but it also
really shows you you
there's no success without struggle and
for those for people who are like how do
i mix how do i mix or jump this step
you don't jump steps you when people are
like i need
i want to be a comic what do i do
get on stage that's the that's it's the
only advice i you need
because it is everyone thinks i say that
i said the first thing that everyone
asked matt is look you're going to think
this sounds like a [ __ ] answer but
the truth is how do you be a doctor you
go to school that's right and you go
through this program that's right do
this how do you become a police officer
you do this and you do how do you become
a comedian you can get on [ __ ] stage
because you can courses everything you
want in your living room it doesn't
start until you get in front of the
microphone and also i don't [ __ ] know
how you're supposed to succeed yeah i
barely figured this [ __ ] out for myself
i'm supposed to know how you're supposed
to succeed in life
have you heard anything about me i don't
know how i'm supposed to do not come to
me with the answers for you man
how do i bounce the i don't know i don't
know you you don't know
is it i
don't know
i don't know my favorite one is really
like what do you think i should talk
about [ __ ]
i don't i don't know you yeah
i don't know i don't have a good answer
for that yeah well thank you for being
here this is let me just say one last
thing go ahead go ahead i'm super happy
for you dude thank you
look we all everybody hits a period when
they're out here when they're like what
the [ __ ] am i doing
am i still doing this in the same place
spinning my [ __ ] wheels and it takes
deep big balls to
believe it to bet on yourself
and you dude
with this studio and in this podcast you
pushed all your [ __ ] chips in
and i have so much respect for that
listen thank you very much i want to say
this i did
i did and i still am yeah and it's the
only way you can be now it's all we can
do now
a [ __ ] pandemic came in and wiped out
stand up yeah yeah yeah
yeah what you gonna do now
i did thank you and i appreciate your
help and support through it
dude absolutely of course and that's why
i'm glad you're sitting in that chair
today because this episode today is a
different episode uh my patreon just hit
100 episodes all right
and
you and i have bared our souls enough
we've come on here and
and
talked about our low lights a lot of
them
um and today i thought it would be nice
if you and i could just sit back
and
i show you
ten of
now there are a hundred episodes but
these are ten of them of our favorites
um and i can show you some clips and we
just kick back and yeah we'll put our
feet up and and you know highlight
y'all's low lights yeah all right that's
what we're going to do today so i'm
going to show you 10 of our favorites
and why are they your favorites were you
well there are so many people out there
okay so
i i started this by just saying look i
know we've got the regular honeydew here
but there's so many people out there
that have these wild stories and i'm
telling you we have an inbox still of
hundreds of emails of the craziest [ __ ]
we just had somebody
email us about being an amputee because
they tried to commit suicide and like
put their legs on a track or some [ __ ]
like that like it's
so i know you're looking at me like that
but that's nothing compared to what
you're about to see
that's something you know how much i
like weird [ __ ]
you know the stuff
he did flew his ass in for this and
thank you for flying
thank you for finding me
yo
listen you know the things that i text
to you
yes things that i can't share no and
you're one of three people i can text
things to right and so the fact that you
have invited me and this i take this as
an invitation as in a compliment that
you would invite me
to see this so i can't wait to laugh
with you so
we're gonna go through ten of them um
and the just so you know the patreon is
called the honeydew with y'all all right
it's five bucks a month if you sign up
for a year you get over a month free and
you get the honeydew a day early ad-free
at no additional cost all right that's
the deal and what we're gonna do uh for
the next 10 weeks beginning may 5th
through july 7th we're going to release
these 10 episodes on the main youtube
channel every thursday for 10 weeks all
right that's what we're going to do all
right so the first episode ironically
was our excuse me the first clip we're
going to talk about ironically was our
second episode
and ironically
this woman has two [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
our second episode wait wait
jess danner
right what do you mean two [ __ ] it has
two [ __ ]
let's let's watch the clip did she have
one big one and just kind of cut it in
half
not at all she had two
i know you're thinking like maybe one's
on here
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but it ain't supposed to be
next to it uh what wait was this a bad
like bicycle accident
when i was 12
i
was walking i was in middle school i
guess yeah middle school i was walking
home from school and i had a really bad
pain in my back and i was like it's got
to be like kidney stones or something
went to the emergency room thought it
was kidney stones spoiler alert turns
out i had uh
what's called uterine didelphus it's two
uteruses
um two uteruses
yep okay so i already have questions all
right so wait
she can have
first of all she can have two
babies she can't have that so
what happens is in her mother's womb
everything doubles she has two uteruses
two cervixes two vaginas okay the vagina
if you want to picture it is almost like
a nose so to speak where you've got a
fleshy material in between but you do
have two
entrances
so i'll never look at a nose again the
same way in my entire life
[Laughter]
okay
but hear me out
she has one kidney
so i'm saying like two [ __ ] one kid
you got two everything you weren't
supposed to have and only one of what
you were supposed to have two of
can we see more from jess danner
uterus something that was excuse me
undiagnosed all this time or did it did
it grow inside you over a course of time
where it's like holy [ __ ]
you grew a second
this is like how to make a mess are
there vitamins you take to grow a second
uterus
in gestation when i was being formed in
my mom's
uterus uh it was cell splitage so the
cells that form
your uterus
cervix and all that are similar to the
ones that build your urinary tract
so instead of
another
kidney uh those cells formed into
another place a uterus
one kidney two
you really said it you like one kidney
you know it's crazy i'm sure those cells
were probably like they were they were
they had a fork in the road and they
were like this side looks a lot more fun
let's go where the other [ __ ] is can
you live with it
you can't
[Applause]
[Laughter]
now listen here's the other great thing
i've met jess danner she came to see me
in baltimore i've met her mom
i've met her sister they're great family
great people this poor girl right here
three people four [ __ ] three people
yeah four puzzles not well
spoiler alert no she's only got one
[ __ ] now she got it fixed she did let's
walk is it fixed
uterus is well the uteruses are gone but
seventh grade was when i first got sick
eighth grade was when i had my first
surgery
they were great
um in middle school high school not so
much like they're like we're prepping
you for life you know you gotta make
sure you get your credits and dirty all
that [ __ ] but
um
she was like are you kidding i got two
[ __ ] i got a lot more to worry about
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
i mean that's the face of someone who's
like i got two [ __ ]
[Laughter]
crazy he's like come on man
teachers will tell you you can't go to
the bathroom
i had a field day with that i mean
i
need to go bathroom and my male teacher
would be like
you got to wait until we're done with
this work she did and i'd stand up and
be like sir i need to change my tampon i
have two uteruses
i am bleeding
like a cut up
i'm like taking animals
[Laughter]
including
punk asses i mean they used to call me
dp
double [ __ ] oh yeah
you didn't have to tell me what it stood
for well i thought see i'm thinking
i thought double penetration
all right yeah she's like no double
[ __ ] yeah but she could be a
three-piece
a teepee
right so like
did did the people in her school people
in high school knew that she had i think
i would have kept that information to
myself i don't know how it got out
because i feel like one guy fingers in
feels two [ __ ] and everyone's gonna
know yeah everybody and he's like hey
you gotta get in there
because you can yeah yeah you can
we both can't yeah
but you know want i want to say she's
the sweetest girl she's done two
episodes she did a post uh follow-up
where she has one [ __ ]
um great people great family and she was
like man as soon as i got that one [ __ ]
she was like out there you know she
wanted to go you don't want to town you
know like [ __ ] yeah try that new [ __ ]
out she didn't but she didn't want to go
to the new position
she didn't
she didn't she didn't go to town with
the double with the dp
i think she did but i think it was
incredibly painful and she also had to
go through all these surgeries and [ __ ]
started wrapping around it like she went
to atlanta for surgeries like this was
you know we sit here 11.
but that's what the show is yeah yeah
yeah that's what the show is five hours
a month all right sign up for a year you
get a month free all right
by the way that episode alone
is worth your five dollars that's just
how we're kicking off all right now by
the way i knew i was in the right place
when i walked in and i just caught the
top
yo i i just i was just looking at the
screen and i said i know i'm in the
right place because it says jeff just
theater two [ __ ] and i was like this
is gonna be a great show
yeah uh okay
the second one here one of my absolute
favorites this is kind of wild um how
about i don't say anything about this
one this is joe sheller okay
uh who made a discovery on his work site
okay okay
so i'm walking through the woods
marking where they're gonna cut down
these uh the trees so they can clear and
get ready for breaking ground and uh
it just rained that day so i'm not very
uh
i'm pretty clumsy
so i was walking and i noticed this
this tan rock sitting out and i go well
i'm not going to step on that because
i'm going to break my ankle and there's
nobody going to i had to climb over a
creek to get here looks like a dinosaur
egg it looks like a dinosaur egg bro
about to be a millionaire
nobody's going to pull my 250 pound body
out of here
so i said all right i'm gonna step next
to it so i stepped on a stick
next to it and it popped the rock i'm
like well that's not normal and i turn
and two eyes or two eye socket look
right up at me hold it right there hold
it right there is that a dead person
did he find a [ __ ] dead person
he he found a he found a skull he found
a human skull on his work site
he did now but so someone put the stick
under there on purpose
now this this is this was just in
december of last year
okay
um and this gets wild let's let's get
watch a little more of this one oh get
the [ __ ] out of it did you [ __ ] yourself
or what bro
all right i have my equipment and i mean
this equipment's eighty thousand dollars
dropped it
i go over the wood i go through the
woods over the you know over this creek
and uh
i get to my truck and i just throw
up all over my truck
[Laughter]
i don't blame him
check this out
by that time the police are calling
they're like hey where are you where are
you
you know i tell them that one cop shows
up i'm like all right cool like let's go
on this hike man
so we go through there
and then by the time we get there and
real quick is he does he have his hand
on his [ __ ] yeah his piece the whole
time wondering if you might be the
[ __ ] that did this because i i
would i'd make you walk in front of me
and i'd be right on that [ __ ] like this
like y'all i think when he saw the puke
on the truck he probably figured it out
so he ended up uh we got there and by
the time we got there there's 20 cop
cars the public works directors there
the whole nine is there and they uh
they tape it off and the sheriff come or
the uh yeah sheriff comes up and he goes
with his duncan in his hand i remember
this
wait a donut or the club
he left the donut in the truck
he gets five feet away from it and goes
yeah that's a human skull we gotta
murder and i'm like
what
whoa
and then uh
i wanna say like the 23rd of the same
month
my wife sends me this link and says hey
i think this is their press release from
the city of the body
so i know how many days later
uh it was like four or five so it was
that next week and finally through
dental records and just stuff in the
bone they finally got it figured out and
was it a male or female who was it was a
it was a female um she had been dead for
18 years
years
years nobody nobody liked her it's a
cold case he felt he solved yeah he just
solved an 18 year old cold case
so he's walking in the woods to land
survey sun's coming up it's in deep
woods illinois
and he steps on this stick and a [ __ ]
skull turns and looks at him
and he hauls the ass he throws up he
calls the his dad first and i go hey
just is this a [ __ ] like yeah is this
a land surveyor's wet dream he's like
yeah so he calls his dad and the first
thing his dad says is like you lucky son
of a [ __ ]
that's what they're always wanting to
see they all they he said they find a
ton of animal skulls deer all that [ __ ]
or whatever got it gotta get it but the
fact of is they're always wondering if
they're gonna see a body so he said he
was also scared because in his mind the
killer was still right there in the
woods you know what i mean even though
it's a skull dude i don't believe it
either
[ __ ]
i would have been like you know what
i'll call for my on my way home so it
turns out that this woman
was murdered uh 18 years ago okay
and this the reason he's there is
surveying the land because they're about
to build like a strip mall or something
in a few days they're gonna break down
and if he doesn't step on this [ __ ]
stick and that skull doesn't spin around
the bulldozers roll right over it push
it deep down into the earth and then
this never happens did they arrest
somebody for the crime let's listen
like a cold case for real
yeah it gets better man it gets better
i love you
go ahead tell me more please the
boyfriend was already in jail for her
disappearance
and they actually found the the bullet
in her head now to his gun
hold it there it was still in the skull
they picked it up and shook it and the
[ __ ] bullet that matched his gun was
still in the skull
now they got him for murder and this is
just before christmas wait the family
gets the closure 18 years ago
but he was in jail he was in jail for
her disappearance they had enough on him
for the disappearance but not enough to
charge for murder
so they got the guy but like
is disappearance against the law
i mean if you have dna and [ __ ] on you i
would say it probably is
i mean i'm high but
i'm gonna guess if you murdered somebody
it's probably not the only thing they
got you yeah that's probably right
yeah
he's not squeaky clean anywhere else no
no i agree yo that would be crazy
i i see i am the opposite of that i
absolutely
do not want to find a body anywhere i
don't either no desire but if you're a
land surveyor you might want to i guess
i mean
i think he he thought he wanted to too
and old joe was like threw up on his
[ __ ]
that's hilarious that he threw up on the
truck this patreon solving cold cases
y'all know that
that is crazy
that's crazy isn't it is there more to
that one
okay
dude now speaking of crazy
this is
this guy his name's mike frampton
uh we call him the death janitor
and mike's job is a guy that comes in
and cleans up the crime scene okay so
let's say you're an old older man that
doesn't have any family and you die in
your home mm-hmm and you're not found
for another three months
mike's the guy
okay
by the way
yeah could be yeah
mike gets the call i guess my phone okay
mike finds me let's check out mike
frampton here
all right since you said gross what's
the grossest like if you're saying it's
gross i gotta believe it's [ __ ]
disgusting
use diapers out of houses and piss jugs
and [ __ ] like got like hundreds of
gallons so like
it's all growth but well so we have
we've had hoarders um and once you hoard
yourself at your bathroom you got to
find a place to put stuff
so
you start pissing water jugs which
aren't made to hold piss for more than a
couple months and then they break a
couple months
a couple what do you mean they're not
meant to hold piss for more than a
couple months they're not meant to hold
pests at all they're not supposed to
have piss in them they don't make milk
cartons be like this one can hold piss
for a couple months
max right here yeah they're not meant to
hold but you know what's meant to help
piss
the [ __ ] toilet yeah and outside yeah
yeah
not a milk carton yo the outside it's
just better than anything that's the
best holder this is the best peel
they're going right now but also if
you're pissing the milk jugs and you've
backed yourself into a literal corner
it's the only place you could piss and
[ __ ] you're
well let's see where is he [ __ ] piss
uh you're just pee in a pop-up is that
right urine breaks the plastic down well
in a water jug because they're meant to
hold water right but a coke bottle
bottles good because they're meant to
hold like an acidic drink right pee in
that one right
so look at this dude but yeah we've done
so many of those where you just end up
spending three four days just dumping
hundreds of gallons of piss and
a lot of the gene comps uh if they're
really bad like if they're weeks long
you end up [ __ ] the next morning and
smelling decomp in your [ __ ]
i was waiting for that
that's my
have you ever even thought of something
like that dude if i you smell d comp in
your [ __ ] if i'm if i'm if i'm [ __ ]
dead body
i am calling in my resignation as it's
coming out of my [ __ ] this is the
call right you're getting too weird this
is what
i quit that's what you're hearing on the
phone you know what i'm saying
i gotta go dead bodies
[ __ ] bro zero chance
does he still work there
what the [ __ ] is wrong well i blame you
man like this is your own problem
and i'm like what's up they're like i
took a [ __ ] this morning and i was like
yeah and he's like it smells like oh and
you would die
i really do feel like i'm taking a
couple of [ __ ] around me you
know
get out of here dude you could say we're
suited i'm not like bathing in it well
you can smell it in your face you can
smell it for three blocks in some cases
because they're so bad
there's thousands of flies flying around
there's sludgy gross dead guys land by
the way like when the the sweater he's
wearing as he's talking to this
it's just so cheerful and he's got like
a four-year-old painting on this
list he sees his place
he's a happy-go-lucky person here's
what's crazy he's well i don't want to
ruin it i'll save it for the end i'll
tell you what happened okay go ahead
take between 60 and 90 pounds of bones
even if the guy was 500 pounds because
the rest of it melts out
oh
is that what you meant by the puddle
yeah yeah so if you're on the third
floor
you're in the basement if you're in a
house if you're in a apartment as long
as you don't land on a seam which has
happened
uh you puddle out
um if you go on a seam we had a girl
call us because she thought the guy's
sewer above broke and was dripping out
of his apartment because she was on the
third floor and he was on the fourth
and she was having
she was in bed
and it ended up being a dead guy and he
finally like leaked through his bed
through the seam and the floor in the
concrete and it was dripping on her back
while she was sleeping yo
first of all
first of all
what yo
yo
i'm gonna need some new skin like i
can't ah
there isn't enough yo there's not enough
soap not only that who do you sue do you
get to kill somebody for that like
what's you what's your your dead juice
[ __ ] drink
who do you get to get mad at for that do
you know what i mean
you can't even you know the worst part
about that you can't get mad at anybody
there's nobody the only person get mad
at just dripped on your [ __ ] back god
is so crazy how crazy is that well let's
see dead body in your [ __ ] and dead
bodies can drip on you which one tell me
which one
sounds worse
knowing that the dead body was inside
you
or that it dripped on you
what do you mean by that would you
rather smell it in your [ __ ] or have it
oh
oh oh god i feel like i'd rather smell
it my [ __ ] me too
i don't want that actively yeah once it
touches me i'll never forget that it was
on me do you know what i mean and even
if it hit my shoulder if someone went to
touch my shoulder i'd be like i wouldn't
do i wouldn't
i wouldn't touch that part of my
i don't know what the [ __ ] gonna
happen oh i've seen walking dead that
seems real yo if some dude
exploded and gooped all over
i don't these are the guys i'm talking
about like these older people that don't
have any family or anything and then
they just die up in their bed and then
the guy is laying there for weeks and
then your body just breaks down and
for so long that it seeps into the
mattress and through the box spring and
onto the floor and then through the
floor like weeks and then it's
actively
[Laughter]
honeydew a day earlier at no additional
cost all right
listen if these three clips haven't well
here's the here's the beautiful thing
these are just clips you are going to
get these full episodes for the next 10
weeks in this order we're doing here uh
on the regular free youtube channel
so
oh that's the first three all right
that's uh that's a tough one that one
how do the next-door neighbors not smell
like something's gonna smell right yeah
but maybe you live out in like nebraska
in the middle of nowhere and
it's just a [ __ ] mailman finally
smelled your son who knows who knows
if a dead guy drift on me i'd never get
over that all right now are we done with
that one kirsten
okay this next one here this is andres
feeda
andres feda
uh this is different this is uh some
crazy [ __ ] here this was um this was a
cliff fall andre fell off a cliff let's
take a look here so mind you i've
reclined this one spot before but i had
two other friends with me now and that
was like six years prior so i'm thinking
like i've done this before i remember
this wall so i'm like i'm climbing up
comfortably i'm doing great i get to
like this one spot where i can chill out
catch my breath
just as soon as i get uh start going
back up i get a little bit higher a
little bit higher and right at the top
i'm crawling over the top no
it's like you're there
at the top yeah i was one foot on top of
the [ __ ] thing my arm i'm literally
wrapped around the boulder i'm just
getting my foot around and my arms just
let go
i don't know what happened
whether it was the wind
my muscles just gave out but it was like
time stopped for a split second it was
like that and i remember just looking
around and just saying [ __ ] in slow
motion because everything just started
to go slowly in front of me down how are
you falling so i have the rock wall in
front of me and i'm holding on and as i
let go i'm just literally like this far
away like this far away from the rock
wall just i'm just trying to grab on to
things i'm pressing my feet into the
wall oh as
as i'm it's just a straight down like i
went up the side and went around to the
to the overlook so it's just a straight
down
so i'm just sliding down pressing
pressing pressing and i remember at one
point i hit this wrist against i'm
pretty sure a boulder or something a
tree but i didn't think anything of it
sliding i landed on my feet right come
on what
what do you mean you think your knees
everything will fall he ain't done yeah
your hips everything's just gonna pop
straight out right
smack down right on that ground just
and everything like who's the superhero
drops in like that with the arm who is
that that drops superman yeah not this
dude
this is andre
that's right oh
[ __ ] let's watch a little more
he's gonna tell you what happened
standing up right i feel this like
this cold metal feeling go from my foot
up through my body and out my head right
you fell how far
the whole 60 feet you fell 60 [ __ ]
feet and landed on your [ __ ] like a
cat
what are the [ __ ] odds of that i land
on my feet and my first instinct into is
like
take a deep breath i'm like all right
i'm alive that's the first thing i say
i'm alive let me grab my phone
i pull off my string bag i pull out my
phone
and i see that my phone is cracked in
half
because i guess it hit it going down on
going down the wall i smacked the side
of the wall and just smashed so
i didn't think anything of this i sat
down
and then when i was sitting wait he's
not hurt
he's not i think this is the beauty of
adrenaline
yeah he's the now listen he's in the
wilderness not not griffith [ __ ] paul
yeah yeah okay not run your kid this
[ __ ] by himself yeah we're
known for the broken phone and he's just
falling 60 foot off a [ __ ] cliff and
landed on his feet and felt electricity
and coldness shoot from his feet through
the blow out the top of his [ __ ] head
and now he's sitting down i mean did his
knees come out of his shoulders
so i laid down on the ground for a
second once i laid down i could i was
lifting my neck and that was about it my
whole body was non-responsive paralyzed
now he's a quadruped in the meantime i'm
laying there in the wilderness feel like
this
like this warm on my head so
naturally i start to feel around and i
feel like this divot and i kid you not i
stick my finger up to this knuckle into
my head
he fingered his own skull in your head
that deep
yeah so when i left pressure i guess the
shock from when my foot connected with
the ground traveled through my body and
blew out the top of my head
out of here pause it pause it
literally blew a hole in his own skull
what the [ __ ]
is that possible
i questioned it i felt maybe there was a
branch that could have broken or
something but here's the thing
wait i wouldn't think you'd even live
from that so i don't know maybe it is
possible that the force of that shot it
up in your
part of your brain
skull excuse me said [ __ ] it and then he
fingered his own head
he was like he's [ __ ] got a finger
inside his skull right now and he's a
quadriplegic okay well he can't be well
paraplegic paraplegic because he's got
his arm can't move his legs and he's
about to [ __ ]
lay there in the wilderness all night
with a broken phone
is there a little more of that wait so
what i need i need an ending to this
story the ending to the story is that he
spent the night in the [ __ ]
wilderness by himself and i was like
were you scared to death with a broken
back everything broken everything and he
was he in a wheelchair
yeah he recovered he fully recovered
yup fully recovered what about that some
of his hikers or something found him the
next i don't know you got to watch the
episode you got to watch the episode man
yo the hole in his head is questionable
to me i kind of feel like he hits a tree
on the way down or some [ __ ] you know if
if that if like a little like if that's
possible but if but a 60-foot fall it's
a six-story building you just fell
straight down and then
on your feet i wonder if that's the best
way to fall if you're going 60 feet
versus just like flat or on your
shoulder or
i don't know he made it andre made it by
the way it all sounds pretty terrible i
just might turn it over and go face
first and get it over with
well speaking of face first get it over
with this next episode really it's
pretty interesting this is that laughs
smith fascinating yeah these are they
range from all different kinds of [ __ ]
this is uh zoe smith
and uh well let's just watch this clip
zoe actually
made a conscious a guy that used to rent
one of the houses on the property that
we live on okay he moved out and was
still sort of vaguely a family friend so
it wasn't like we were important people
in the wedding we were the ones that i
just invited you know how there's like
but you didn't take a date with you
no i took a friend that didn't know him
at all and we were just hanging out all
right and meet this guy
yeah i met this guy and we were sort of
talking with a group of people and my
ex-boyfriend was also at that wedding
and me and him were good friends and he
saw that i liked this guy that we were
talking to and he had gone to school
with that guy because i was 19 and my
ex-boyfriend and the guy that i met
um were both seven years older than me
so he was like hey i know him
do you know that he's gay and he's hiv
positive and i was like i don't really
care because i'm 19 and i'm dumb and i
don't give a [ __ ] about it you really
did have the attitude of i don't care
well
when he told me those two things he's
gay and he's got hiv the one that pissed
me off the most was that he was gay i
was like damn
like
i was like that girl's my shot yeah yeah
and so i was like [ __ ] i really like
that guy and um
and then i was like oh i will just be
friends because he was funny so you
believed him though you didn't think he
was [ __ ] blocking or trying new do you
know you really didn't believe him like
we're good friends and he said and i
know that he was just trying to be like
hey by the way that guy's crazy so like
you know
beware
and i thought oh well who cares i'll
just be friends with him like he'll be
my fun gay friend because whatever but
obviously i still was into him so we
started hanging out that
wedding was in like september which in
new zealand is spring so it was like the
beginning of the summer um
and then that whole summer we were
hanging out and secretly i was like i
really like you you're really hot and i
wanna i wish that you weren't gay
and then we got drunk hooked up hooked
up and i was like hey i thought you were
gay and he's like hey like you know wait
wait wait wait is that so is that all
this is just i'm not gay anymore this is
the sign for
i i'm not sure what the sign is for that
but it might be hey you just had sex
with an hiv positive person
knowingly
uh without caring
so let's see what happens
um
he just we just started hanging out and
hooking up so we were hanging out we'd
have a good time here well hold on i'm
sorry i'm i know i'm stopping you
because my girlfriend you know he's hiv
positive
and but i'm dumb
that's fine look we all are at that age
we all have made plenty of mistakes i
mean that's a big you can hold on there
hold it there
listen when you're 19 you're like hey
i'm gonna [ __ ] in this parking lot dumb
you're not hey
i'm gonna [ __ ] somebody who has hiv yeah
i just want to step in like i did dumb
[ __ ] when i was 19. you know what i mean
like i would grab a six-pack of beer and
run out of 7-eleven dumb you know but
not be like let's see if i'm gonna die
well see that's the difference it
is
i guess it's all matters and what you
think is dumb you know
okay we are a lot dumber but smarter
yeah i think so i think so are you
having an open dialogue about it at all
or are you just not addressing it are
you ever asking him are you ever asking
if hey maybe this time we should put a
condom on or
any of that
the thing is is that it was so this is
going to make me sound really pathetic
but it was so hard for him for me to get
him to be into me
that
when he was into me i was like let's not
ruin this with like clinical with aids
with death let's talk
with certain
death that is [ __ ] crazy about that
so
she didn't
get hiv she did
she did do we have that part
i don't know if we have that
yeah okay let's not ruin
[Music]
yeah it makes me sound really dumb and
in hindsight i'm like what's wrong with
me
so yeah she's she got it because that's
i say on the show that's how it works
yeah that's that's how you get it that's
how it works yeah that is how you get it
you have
unprotected sex with a person who's hiv
positive that's exactly how that happens
yeah yeah so she's hiv positive she
doesn't have aids but she's hiv positive
for most of us learning a second
language in high school or college
wasn't exactly a high point in our
academic careers i started taking
spanish in eighth grade they made me
take it up until like 11th and that d
brought my gpa down still got out of
there with a 3.0 suck at liberty high
school now thanks to babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or you just have some free time
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world babel's 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 100 language experts their teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective with babel you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german i
started taking spanish i've been wanting
to take it get that d up to a b and
actually me espanol
is excellent
plus babel speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
and your accent there are so many ways
to learn with babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcasts games
videos stories and even live classes
plus it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee start your new language
learning journey today with babel right
now you can save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
honeydude that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com
honeydew for up to 60 off your
subscription babble language for life
you guys have been hearing me talk about
the how to buy home podcast for a while
now so whether you've already started
looking or even if you haven't
considered buying a home yet you've
probably heard some horrible headlines
and the good news is listening to the
how to buy a home offers a clear concise
path to navigate the entire home buying
process how to buy a home host david
cedoni answers questions like how the
hell do i do this in 2022 what if i'm
not ready yet how do i even start can i
buy a home with a 600 credit score david
has helped make buying a home a reality
for so many people check out some of his
interviews like episode 71 with randy a
honeydew listener who had no job and
zero credit a year ago dude just closed
on a 200 000 3 bedroom home on a half
acre after contacting david and david
can help you no matter what stage you're
in he can even connect you with a great
realtor in your area get the latest on
the how to buy a home podcast and make
this the last year you rent listen to
the how to buy home podcast today find
how to buy a home on youtube and
wherever you listen to podcasts now
let's get back to the duke that is i i
have to tell you
i bet i bet you she's one of like four
people in the history of the world who
was like you got your hiv positive yeah
what the [ __ ]
yeah
i can't imagine wearing double digits
with that number it better be the best
piece of [ __ ] i've ever i mean cause it
should be the best pizza [ __ ] i've
never had now this is the question
though are you getting magic johnson hiv
yeah yeah right
i mean that's that i don't know i don't
think so it sounded like it was
australia or new zealand i can't
remember now
this next one here
this one's a little bit of a wild card
this is my girl randy kiosky here randy
kiosky
uh actually made history uh she was the
first female
uh in a gang
that she was part of in chicago ran that
for a little while was like
you know
she was the first female ever in that
game initiated in and allowed to be in
that gang she made history in the gang
world and like in the underworld they
knew her uh and then she transitioned
out of that world eventually and now
into a bd
sm dominatrix let's take a listen to
randy she's got the best tell me what
your job she's in nashville here she
brings you in and you're a dominatrix
apprentice at this point so what do you
have what do you do
so the first day that i was there i
i um got a guy for five thousand dollars
she's like this is a big ticket item
like you know we talked about them like
they were cattle
and
so
he wanted to be branded
so i had to get this iron hot
and and [ __ ] brand him on his ass
dude had a wedding ring on i'm like his
wife is going to see this and be like
yeah why is there a big pain
into your [ __ ] ass you know but yeah
that's what he wanted that was my first
day there
first day on the job hold on first day
on the job she must have gone home like
what the [ __ ]
else and pay you
five thousand i've been learning about
these i think they're called cash pigs
or something like this these are guys
that want women yeah just they want to
spend money on you like that's what they
get off on that's their fetish this dude
is coming in to get something on his ass
that's gonna be that's also it's a bra
that's gonna hurt for a long time yeah
yeah yeah sitting down is going to be a
problem not a tattoo this is going to be
a [ __ ] thing for a minute
i get so many questions
first of all like
i mean how did he pick his brand
absolutely i don't know either i really
wanted to i mean i'd like to talk to
that dude and be like
yo man
but but
if the first day was branding
you must have gone home like
oh
she must have gone home either thinking
i can't do this or this is going to be
the best job well i don't want to spoil
it for you but randy leans into it
[Laughter]
let me just say a lot of pegging a lot
of it is that this guy gave you five
thousand dollars
just to brand him
yeah i mean i like pissed in his mouth
too but the main thing that
he wanted was to be
the
vegan
thing was brandon wait that's an
assignment in my mouth it better be the
main [ __ ] thing on the menu no
it's not ain't no warm up you're telling
me pissing in the mouth as the appetizer
i would have said piss on that hot
back there and pull it off [ __ ]
piss it on your mouth that's the hummus
that's not even the full one
and that's the garlic bread
that's the garlic knot
piss it in your mouth yo she said that
so casually yeah i mean she had me piss
in his mouth but that wasn't the main
thing oh well there's more josh there's
more jobs do they drink it when they're
pissed in the mouth
probably probably i don't know how you
don't
i love this [ __ ] show
you pissed in his mouth
just lays down you just stand over him
and piss in his mouth
yeah
why does she say so matter-of-factly she
says to me like i'm the weird one yeah
yeah like yeah yeah yeah you you spotted
over him like he was a toilet and pissed
in his mouth and told him he was a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and to drink my
piss and he drank gargle it there's your
answer yeah i said gargle it before you
[ __ ] drink it you pig and then you
did
and then he's like thanks very much i'm
out of here with my sore ass
no he wasn't allowed to say thank you i
didn't want him to i you speak when
you're spoken to if i don't ask you a
question you don't [ __ ] say [ __ ] yeah
and then you would ring around
i don't know if you heard that
she would pull it out real fast put your
arm in your [ __ ] after your elbow and
then she would pull it out real quick
and it'll suck your ass out that
prolapses and then you punch it back in
i think rocky did that
at all
that was his training i think right he
couldn't afford a real gym you know
that's if it was a combo movie of rocky
in philadelphia like if they did a combo
like right
[Laughter]
oh
dude wait there's more to this there's
more could there be oh there is
sometimes you know there's more
clouds like a donut you'd ring around it
and it would it would kind of bleed but
it would be mixed with lube so it would
be lube and blood
and the smell of that smells like
plastic
i'm sorry
are you telling me that you have shoved
your fist you've punched your fist up
men's [ __ ]
oh yeah as hard as i could i mean i know
about prolapse anuses because of tom
segura
exactly you know they're touch uh
but i didn't know
i i didn't i just thought that was
something that happened if you over used
it i didn't know you could actually take
somebody's [ __ ] yeah like girls would
do anal porn like that got it well what
happens is they can stretch around your
your arm
so they they tighten up like they're
doing like kegels you know guys where
else are you getting fisting a guy's
[ __ ] up to the elbow prolapsing his
anus for five dollars a month
over a month free if you sign up for
free yeah it's five
it's five thousand if you go to her
and
and i'm like okay and then i pull it out
so when they tighten that's what
suctions around your arm and that's when
you pull it out because where are you
learning
what what training do you have
to learn how to yank a man's [ __ ] out
of him
she's got a name it's just it's on the
job training
she's practicing on your ass yeah she
probably she probably did it wrong a
couple times like what does that look
like if she does it wrong a couple times
she said one guy she couldn't get it
back in she just couldn't and they have
to call an ambulance and then they come
and you're humiliated they take you out
of the bdsm place with your [ __ ] out
you're probably holding it like this on
the street
i wonder if they put it on a little
stretcher next to you or a pillow or a
little pillow
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right this is i'll give you a heads
up now this one's a little difficult all
right
uh this is
what does that mean difficult
this is a mike farahani he took sleep
meds and
one in like 15 000 can cause priapism
okay what is that a prolonged direction
you know when you see the viagra like if
you have an erection
okay well he's only trying to get a good
night's sleep he's not trying to get his
[ __ ] on he's trying to get his sleep on
so he took these meds and
it's rare but it happens
some of these meds can make your dick
hard for hours
this guy's dick has been hard
for kirsten do you remember how long
that sounds terrible and he's now at the
hospital to get it just [ __ ]
everybody taken care
everybody
who's coming in next
[Laughter]
well he's in excruciating pain and he is
now at the [ __ ] emergency room to get
this taken care of okay
so she does this for about an hour every
five minutes i get a new injection but
she actually hits the glands this time
every five minutes
yeah
every dozen a dozen shots in your dick
to try to get this thing down so they're
trying to pull the blood out wait a
second it's got 12 needles in his dick
to try to get the blood out of this
[ __ ] engorged
wait a second sausage he's got okay i
got it i got a couple questions go ahead
he's going to answer them for you too
well for my first question
he's he's in a lot of pain
does it hurt to have a hard on for that
long yes it's excruciating he said he
said it felt like it was gonna just blow
up
well again you can't just jerk off no it
didn't help
i'm sure he tried he tried everything
yeah yeah yeah piss it all of it trying
anything he could
and so that's why he's now at the
hospital yeah you're right that's not
your first choice you're right you're
not like my i got hard on time to go to
the hospital
it's definitely not your first
you're right
i mean after hour three or four you're
like man yeah i gotta go somewhere
[Music]
i don't know about this y'all get some
pictures of it because it's bigger than
it's ever been but jesus christ
oh yeah if you're on tinder that's your
[Music]
wait okay all right let's watch all
right okay he gets into it yeah
eventually but here's the
yeah
man i'm sorry dude okay go ahead so now
you've got a dozen needles in your dick
the reason that picture is so gnarly is
that their surgery we're gonna show you
the pictures yeah so this is their
aftermath
the reason that picture is so gnarly is
i didn't realize at the time they're not
capturing the blood anywhere the little
tip of the needle they put in the
syringe there's no syringe they just put
those needles in and just let it drain
and it's just going off it's just
they're not pulling it out or anything
they're just pot and no that's right
they're not pulling it up a syringe
they're just poking it and like
holes in it so that it just shoots blood
out and relieves itself because it's
it's about to explode
explode do we have the pic you want to
show the picture now you have it set for
the end
what would happen if they didn't do that
i'll show you
oh did it explode oh he sent us a
picture of it so get ready for this but
did it had it exploded
no they were just trying to [ __ ] get
it done
but
whoa [ __ ] yankees by the way this is not
the only time it's happened to this poor
[ __ ] okay he did it again well
we're gonna listen let's see if we got
it more of it can you say that
yeah well it's gonna be in that it's
gonna be in the post
it's just spraying out
no it's yeah it's first it sprays and
then it just drips like a like a faucet
that will drip drip drip drip
so
they're not capturing the blood is he
awake here's the problem don't stop
staying down listen to this um
they they completely drain it and they
they literally squeeze the blood out
they're grabbing the needles are like a
sham
so they're grabbing the top they just
bring it out
then they let go and i can feel it just
right back up
wait they drained all that blood out and
your dick's still worn by the way you
know part
just a little bit of them was like
that's right
[Laughter]
he
where's the blood coming from that's
pumping it in there
the the the blood vessels just aren't
constricting enough and it's just
they're just wide open like a fire hose
allowing blood to come right back in
so they start
simultaneously aspirating the blood out
and injecting the phenylephrine in
and finally they're like
i'm like can i have some water i'm dying
here and they're like we can't even give
you water because
you might need surgery and if you're
under general anesthesia anything in
your stomach you'll you have the
potential to throw he's awake he is
awake so
finally they're like local
oh and simultaneously they have to flush
it out so they're injecting saline
and it's crazy like how many [ __ ]
needles we're talking about in this
procedure
dozens it sounds like dozens 50 60
sticks
50 sticks in his dick
no
yo at one needle i'll be like i'll take
my chances right there get some sleep
yeah
just try why did this happen to him more
than once because he took what he didn't
realize is the first time i think he
took some medication and it happened and
then after like a couple days or
something maybe it went down and then he
took it but he didn't put it to that
and then he took it because he was
taking other medications i may have this
wrong okay and then he did it a second
time and that's when they linked it to
the the sleep medication now
now
you it's five dollars a month you could
ask it's five dollars a month if you
sign up for a year you get over a month
the needle in the dick yeah bro because
watch the episode you'll see the rest of
it you know what hurts a lot
those local anesthetic needles yeah they
do the the prick yeah so he had to get
a bunch of those yeah to get 60 [ __ ]
needles in his dick
no
again i need something to get mad at
like who can i get there's no one to get
mad at
you just get a
unlucky dick unlucky dick bro
now speaking of unlucky dicks no uh this
guy this one's a while and this is one
of our more wild stories for sure
uh this is dan batisse uh
have you ever been paying attention to
the first six what do you mean more wise
i've done seven but i have seven this
one is well you'll see this is dan
batisse and dan is making a purchase
he's a heroin addict at the time okay um
and he's making a purchase in philly
in the open air drug market back and i
think it was the 90s all right and this
was his experience
going to this particular deal was it
like a farmer's market it was sort of
like
i mean kinda they were like put it over
in this [ __ ] neighborhood and we
don't give a [ __ ] no [ __ ] that sort of
baltimore philly style [ __ ] like hey do
it over there leave everything else
alone
okay so i remember
that day
i went and i bought my [ __ ] dude
okay so hold on let me set this up a
little more he clearly has a [ __ ]
weed by the way it's not weed bro he's
heroin he does still i
i mean i'm not sure
i'm not sure
[Music]
so damn buys his drugs normally from a
guy named gordo okay
so gordo is a dealer who uh he goes to
sea
and gordo is a big fat dude in a
beautiful suit and he's got like a 44 or
a desert eagle he had a desert eagle i
believe he's okay
and he wouldn't do
uh he wouldn't [ __ ] flex on you in a
way like with the gun like show to
everything he would be like poppy look
at this it's beautiful nickel plated
just to let you know i got this
[ __ ] right right he doesn't need
to be like yeah [ __ ] what's up
just letting you know i love this
[ __ ] gun that i have on and it's
always loaded yeah right yeah yeah
i wish i could see i want to take it for
a drive i got a ferrari in the garage
that's right let me know letting you
know that this is present
and what happens is every time you go
buy drugs from gordo there's a resident
crackhead that stands nearby and after
you buy your drugs when you turn around
and leave crackheads like hey can i get
a little while around everybody's like
get the [ __ ] out of here okay so these
are the three characters involved in
this story
wait for this one i remember that day
i went and i bought my [ __ ] dude
and i remember walking away and then
[ __ ]
jerry
walking back and forth peace jerry's the
crackhead the resin and crackers
i remember him passing me
like he walked right by me [ __ ] head
down just
going for it dude
as i'm walking away i hear
hey [ __ ]
and my head goes oh [ __ ] did i not give
him enough money you know because you
just [ __ ] here's a stack of money
give me my drugs and then you beat the
[ __ ] feet
dude i hear hey [ __ ] and all of
a sudden
i hear
as jerry is running at me
are you understood all right so hold on
here carson so i thought jerry had
already ran past him he did but now
jerry's running away from so jerry's
past
uh dan
walking toward gordo okay i'm dan i'm
turned around i'm walking this way
jerry's coming at you right i'm still
walking away but now jerry's coming back
and jerry's walking the same direction
i'm walking away from gordo oh got it
yep yep so jerry's right between gordo
and me you follow yeah all right
i turned around dude and i looked and
all this okay stop so now i'm looking at
you you're gordo yeah i've turned around
to see why jerry who's coming running at
me jerry's facing me and you and i are
facing each other you with me yeah all
right here we go
i turn around dude and i look and all of
a sudden his [ __ ] face is
all over me
what
oh my god what do you mean
he shot him in the face
did you just say his face is all over
his face is all over me dude
gordo shot that [ __ ] in the back
of the head and his [ __ ] face just
went
oh oh no
yo
no i need a
yo gordon i need a free bag for that
yo he gave me a facial for real
yo yo you you put jerry's face on my
face shot someone's face onto his face
[ __ ]
no
oh i'd still be doing heroin then for
sure
oh there's more to the story
what else could happen no [ __ ] what are
you talking about right now hold on
you're telling me that you thought he
was talking to you so you turn to
see
and he shoots this guy's
skull apart and it splatters all over
you
what the [ __ ] oh my god holy [ __ ] dude
but by the way if i haven't played
this if i didn't have a drug problem
before i would now
what dude i mean you're lucky the
bullets didn't go through him and hit
you right the fact that i didn't get
shot that day is insane to me what do
you know what happened why did he try to
charge gordo what the [ __ ] he's doing
he dude he went up [ __ ] was this this
is his size mission oh i just wow dude
he went up asked for a pack took the
pack and [ __ ]
started running on ass trying to get
away
gordo is not a runner right he ain't
alright bro he's like three bills that's
right carter's not a runner but he told
but that desert eagle can fly you know
and he shot that [ __ ] in the
back of the head and it sprayed and
dude i
literally picked [ __ ] hair
brains and skull fragments out of my
[ __ ] everything for like
20 years old
20 minutes
listen
i don't even remember yes you did yeah
dude i just turned around and all of a
sudden some dudes dude and i remember it
i remember it in slow motion where
literally like all of a sudden you see a
face
and then it just goes
like the inside of his head played
peek-a-boo
dude disintegrate is not the word for it
what happened to his eyeballs what if an
eyeball was like do you hear what he
says it smelled did we i'll see if he
says that
dude the [ __ ] that a 45 magnum
45 magazine
when it comes to the back is something i
wouldn't wish dude i wouldn't wish it on
my worst enemy it dude it it covered me
from [ __ ] head to toe
and i sat there for an hour and a half
waiting for the cops to come p.s
doing heroin yeah
scooting up in the car with someone's
[ __ ] all over them dude well by the way
i would have
shot the heroine too are you kidding me
whatever drug i had in my pocket
i i can't decide what's worth dead guy
dripping on me
dead goop that's worried way worse a
drop of a drops of dead goop or
blood brain snot
when i knew it was real there's
something he said it smelled like
pennies yeah that's right and if you
want to hear what happens the rest of it
oh he's not done doing heroin and he
ain't done with gordo either there's
more to that story i love the fact that
he waited for the cops but was like i
might as well shoot up
what am i gonna do for 20 minutes
dude all right
now we gotta go we're gonna go a little
lighter here on this one here this one's
just a fun really [ __ ] up one i'm
trying to picture that in my head
yeah
because
first of all
yo good shot by gordo
thank god right yeah
thank god good shot by because i think
it probably goes through
other parts of his body
into i don't know because i don't know
what gun it was i'm over here joking he
says 45 meg i don't even think that's
real yeah but again it might be i don't
know yeah i don't know it doesn't matter
it was powerful enough to explode his
face and i know when you say snot that
you're [ __ ] yeah gets that's that
happened oh my god um so this one this
is zek johnson uh zek had an interesting
story his mom
i don't know how much we have set up
here but his mom and her girlfriend were
a one-two punch okay basically they'd
roll the parties together
and um his mom zek's mom would tell um
her partner in crime literally look i
like josh josh is hot and then they
would [ __ ] roofy you
and then you would go lay down because
you're not feeling well in a bedroom and
then zack's mom will come in and she'd
[ __ ] you
okay
why why wouldn't she just try to [ __ ] me
that's a great point
but also we don't know what sex model is
yeah good point good boy
by the way it's it's
we already saw somebody get aids on this
show on purpose
it's zach not zach it is zach it's
z-e-c-h i believe zach zec johnson so uh
she as anybody who names their kids zack
probably does that to people so his mom
was obviously not a great mom to him and
he's sort of trying to work on things
now and and they go to this little party
together
and uh he's not feeling well
he's not female so he goes to lay down
at this house now here's the thing did
the partner in crime roofie him the
partner in crime
roofied
the right guy
and he went to lay down
in the back the last bedroom all the way
down the halls like a three or four
bedroom house he's not feeling well
legit for some from being shit-faced and
black-out drunk
so they put him in the first bedroom
down the hall oh no well you know when
you're drunk looking just the [ __ ]
she ain't going extra mile no no she's
picking door number one
and let's see josh what's behind door
number one i open my eyes
and but it's still kind of hazy you're
not sure what's happening
and all i see in front of me is just
this pair of tits
i mean tits are out
yeah
i mean i'm talking not maybe six or
eight inches from my face i mean it's
just tits and my first rick my cognitive
thought is
oh my wife's trying to do a little
something something while we're here
all right let's see
and i and i'm slowly trying to like
collect myself to
get myself in that hit oh yeah and then
i start feeling my belt buckle kind of
get fiddled with you know that kind of
like first of all your mom already took
her titties out and your belt is not
she's not even got you undressed yet she
is ready to go oh
my god in all fairness the room is dark
no matter
your mom's it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter it doesn't no it doesn't doesn't
matter at all oh your mom's ready to go
so he said um and i met him
girls get ambrose let's let's see what
happens
the next thing i know is i just hear the
door wham slam open
and i the lights go on and you like kind
of feeling when you're dark from light
you're kind of stunned for a minute i
kind of look over and i see
my sister
and my wife over her shoulder oh my just
like what the [ __ ] is happening
in this room wait his mom is on top of
him with her with her titties out and
his belt buckle on oh
no
yo
yo i have got a party not at the house
at a party by the way bunch of people
are i think anywhere it's not great but
that yo you gotta be at that next
thanksgiving like
what's up yeah
[Laughter]
nice titties mom
[Laughter]
i've never been in a fraternity sorority
party like this have you this is
american pilots oh
and she was on the prowl
wait so what happened so
i i don't admittedly i don't see my
my mother
i just look over and see her and i hear
her yell is what the [ __ ] are you doing
and i'm like wait there's her and my
wife
who the [ __ ] and i look up and
it's my mother oh my god with her
kitties out with
and she's looking at my sister already
what does the next birthday card say
sorry about that i'll wait to hear his
mom's response she's she's gonna listen
if anything she's a woman of her words
she's gonna [ __ ] she's gonna she has
to respond to this
i mean how could you not yeah i'm like
oh
well
and she and
mom
uh i recall mom saying she's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing in here get out
[Music]
she's not done yeah
and my sister goes do you realize who
you're trying to [ __ ]
and kind of points at me and she's like
yeah steep
and kind of sees me and goes
well that's not who i expected
but
i'm just here to get laid no no
no
titties
no
no
no
no
no what did he do
i mean was he like hey shut the door
we're here
i'll tell them
that's what your mom said
i'm just here to get laid
my god dude
titties out
in front of his wife and her own sister
but she hasn't jumped off of him no
she's still yeah
what the [ __ ] going on back there
oh
yo how would you how do you recover from
that in a i told him straight up i said
no disrespect here but you look like a
guy whose mom would try to [ __ ]
i don't think he disagrees
because he is yeah yeah
that's the look right there yeah because
that
oh
okay all right
this is number 10 here for you yeah
yeah
does he have a relationship with her i
mean he almost had an intimate woman
how do you recover from that i don't
think you do dude i don't think you do
um
speaking of how do you recover from that
wow you're teeing me up nicely here this
next guy this is ian woodford
this guy is in here he's in he's in a
dump truck he's doing his job another
truck's coming the other way but that
guy's got a red light our guy here ian
has got the green light all the way
and they're not sure if this guy was
texting
if he fell asleep they don't know but
this guy's coming at him full speed in a
crane truck all right dump truck train
trucks let's listen full speed ahead
both i'm i'm in a full size dump truck
with a trailer with a full-size
excavator on the back and you have a
load of time do you have a load in the
truck too
yeah i had some gravel okay so you have
gravel it's backwards
[Laughter]
i was coming down the hill and um there
was a lady
so like you're coming down state street
and there's a road right here but it's
only a right-hand turn or left-hand turn
it dead ends into a cornfield
there's a lady waiting for me to go by
there's a guy in a crane truck coming
trucking down the other side of the hill
because you go down in this valley and
i don't know it's never been proven but
everybody even people at his company say
he was texting and driving he says he
fell asleep
um
but uh
he i guess slipped up seen her
clipped her
the best thing that could have happened
in the whole entire world that day
was to be pushed her she's like some
just
right out of high school girl in this
little focus she would have been
demolished in between those two trucks
oh so he clips her driver's side tail
light and pushes her into the field
and then hits me straight on his crane
comes through takes off this side of my
face all the way back to my ear what my
my steering wheel cuts me in half
what
yeah the stairway patrol said i usually
hit over 100 g's they marked me as uh
that
most of the reports say
that wait his face that side of his face
still moves this guy
had a train
crane truck come through as he explained
slice the side of his head it flops over
like deli meat he said everything's
exposed and he dies he flatlines the
[ __ ] steering wheel that cut him in
half what happened was he hit the
steering wheel so i've never even
comprehended this hit the steering wheel
so hard that it pushed his ribcage
through his back like his skin it was
exposed it broke through the [ __ ] like
get the compound fracture rib cage going
through your back
okay through your back he's not done
he's got more injuries than that a lot
more kicked my door open
and you know how on like a big dump
truck a diesel truck like that the fuel
tank the diesel tank is part of the
steps to get in yeah
that wasn't [ __ ] there man so i go to
get out and the steps are wrinkled up
like this the steps are wrinkled up
comes right through me and out
and cuts up through my liver
oh and by the way oh my god hold on hold
on wait a [ __ ] second
how is he walking out of the truck
i don't know how he's walking out
because he's got deli meat on the head
yeah he's got somebody incredible hulk
punched him in the chest his ribs came
out the back and now he's falling off
this thing and it sliced him up into his
liver
oh my god he's not done did you just say
all your ribs came out of your back yeah
i forgot to say
[Laughter]
how do you forget that one that's trauma
dude listen to this
i told this story a lot man so wait
you're telling me that
you don't remember obviously but just
force a habit you kick the door open and
you're about to step down that's why
your body is dropping so quick you're
expecting a step to be there i guess i
don't i don't remember i just and that's
bent up and it [ __ ] just slices you
yeah i go to step out and i fall and it
cut it cuts my liver right in half good
comes right through
comes straight up and cuts me in half
and that's now here's the thing about
this guy
he looks great there yeah i told him you
look great and he's like i am i'm
frankenstein so there that underneath
the hat is not great underneath the
shirt's not great not only is it not
great under the shirt you don't really
recover from your rib cage being shoved
through your your back
we have some pictures of the accident
here i'm going to show you
um so this is if you take a look here
this is the accident here that's his
truck there chris kirsten circling this
is the crane truck over here you see
that crane is out right there you see
that
this is his truck he's in the full-size
dump truck look at it ripped the front
of a dump truck off that crane went
right through the window right through
the window where he's sitting
that's his seat right there
all right oh my now look at this this is
the steering wheel that punctured
his entire rib cage all right now we're
gonna start to see
some of the injuries so that's that's a
minor scrape
compared to
uh what we're about to see here so
that's his torso right
that's there that dude
that's another part of it they're put
they put mesh and wire in there to
rebuild him
uh and then let's take a look at that
that's what is that well that's what
happens when you don't the second [ __ ]
that's what that's what it looks like
from the first
i was so good at that that is what a
stomach looks like when you don't have a
rib cage all he has he doesn't have
excuse me an abdomen he has no abs he
just has the stomach you see that's a
ball right there what do you mean he
doesn't have he does not have ab muscles
where did what where are they they're
shredded and destroyed when that
steering wheel hit him they're able to
save his stomach so he can still eat and
things like that but he has no are there
any more than that or is that it
yeah so that's what he has left there
might be even more graphic one was that
is there a more is was there another one
up on the patreon post or was that all
of them
okay yeah that's what his stump so he's
he's bandaged up like he has to every
day he's wrapped you know what i mean
pain meds all the time and that's what
he said he he flatlined i believe a
couple times dude died it was one one of
the things i really wanted to do when i
started this was talk to somebody that
had gone through that so
he's got a daughter i believe i know he
has a child he's married uh for your
post
i think pre and they're still together
at least they were um but that was the
thing he hated the pain meds
but the only way he could function was
to be on him so he's trying his
best to try to figure out how to live
like that not on so many pain meds that
make him not him yeah you know his
brain's still there he didn't have brain
damage or anything oh what about the
deli meat deli meat just take it it just
sliced the skull and and skin and it
didn't hit the brain it just
massive dude that's
you know that's what the patreon is like
now
because i love you and i love this show
and this show i'm gonna drive like five
miles an hour out of here oh this show's
five dollars a month sign up for a a
year you get over a month free you're
getting a honey do a day early ad-free
at no additional cost
and um
we're gonna give you a bonus clip all
right one of our favorite guests he's a
repeat guest we've only had a couple
ironically one was the girl with two
[ __ ] um but
this is mike frampton again the death
janitor who this time
came back and gave us
a little bonus story
now i'm not sure where we start with
this so let me see where we are with
this kirsten but this one it was oh okay
so hold there
so this is mike frampton now he's
changed his look up a little bit
definitely
also this is winner mike he has opened
up a donut shop
he's since stopped doing death janitor
calls his donut shop tragically dipped
doing well out there too
that's awesome
congratulations dude
yeah going from cleaning up dead
disgusting dude you've been making
people filling their belly you made a
great career choice so he told a couple
of stories he he actually had gone uh
some animal ones he had to have animal
removes uh [ __ ] like that uh but removal
but um he told a story about a guy who
committed suicide so he's
there was a kid at the university of
toronto who jumped off his dorm or a
parking structure and committed suicide
and he's laying on the [ __ ] sidewalk
of the campus they call our boy mike
framp and then to come clean it up and
they're like hey how long is this going
to be because we got a mental health
march coming by in an hour
no yeah he's got a clean
mark
oh no
so that is uh
you know the people who were in charge
of the march i mean somebody was like
hey listen i get some news could be good
could be real bad
it's real [ __ ] somebody committed
suicide in the middle of the march we're
just trying to clean up the body so you
might want to think of an alternate
route and he's like i ain't getting this
up in 90 minutes
this is a body spot i don't know i'm not
just picking this thing up moving it
on the ground
so this one this is another
i would say ironic
suicide okay
but this one it was a via train and the
guy got hit and lot he was a young guy
he had headphones in supposedly and he
didn't hear it supposedly my opinion is
when the gates are down and stuff is
flashing and even if you have rock and
rap or whatever is going on you can hear
and see all of this stuff so i think it
was still a suicide because every other
time i was there it was a suicide
if you get hit by a train
you didn't not see the train
i mean it was next
it's a really good point this guy got
hit
launched into a sign which i still have
in my shed this is the best
nostalgia purposes i think he's like
[ __ ] dexter
[Laughter]
it's it's a sign that got bent in half
and it's very thick metal and it was the
1 800 number for the mental health
it's all just wait hold on now and it
cut this guy's head right off
he got hit and the way he hit the sign
he thank you
train hit him so hard it [ __ ] threw
him into the suicide sign and a suicide
sign cut his head off that is
that's like a weird
but the commercial of the post like
those metal posts that they put the
signs on severed his leg and he was
wearing work boots and his steel toe
boot went like 300 yards down the tracks
and through one of those warming rooms
and blew all of the glass out of it no
like a [ __ ] like a like an action
movie like
and it blew like i think 17 panels of
glass holy [ __ ] yeah
what a way to go bro yo that dude
he's up in heaven like
well wait yeah let's take a look we have
a photo to show you dude yeah we got a
bonus photo for this this is like
this dude has a good sense of humor if
he kept this sign
he kept an open donut shop yeah that
sign should be up in the donut shop
people should be like why is that up
don't worry about it dude thank you this
is this is the episode this week thank
you for doing this it was nice to have a
a a week off so to speak and highlight
y'all's low lights so
thank you joshua for being here
amazing thank you so much being you dude
thank you so much please promote
everything you'd like again uh podcast
with me my son uh called hey man which
is a fantastic podcast comedian
joshwolf.com for tour dates i'm in grand
rapids and um
i forgot where the other place was in
may grand rapids oh and madison on stage
there it is madison and uh comedian
joshua.com for tournaments joshua comedy
for everything else brother thank you so
much
and thank you out there if you are
interested in the patreon and i hope you
are it's five bucks a month when i'm
telling you we don't do levels or
anything of that if you sign up for a
year you get over a month free you get
the honeydew a day early ad free at no
additional cost all right uh and
beginning next week
every thursday for 10 weeks
you're going to get a free episode these
10 that we went over today maybe we'll
do 11. we'll see but you're going to get
those full episodes on the free youtube
channel and if you're interested in the
patreon and you want to support i
appreciate you all
please subscribe you can get all the
info ryan sickler.com as always ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you